bonjour à tous et bienvenue à ceux qui
nous rejoignent sur public sénat dans un
quart d'heure place aux traditionnelles
questions d'actualité nous sommes jeudi
auront lieu à 15 heures très précises
juste à côté nous dans la salle ici de
l'hémicycle nous sommes salle des
conférences au sénat mais bien sûr vous
qui nous suivez vous savez que
l'actualité ici au sénat si bien sûr
l'examen du texte sur le traité européen
il sera voté en milieu d'après-midi avec
nous pour en parler
le ministre en charge des relations avec
le parlement à la vie d'alice bonjour
merci de venir répondre à quelques
questions juste avant ces questions mais
avant le vote de ce texte ici au sénat
mais avec nous également delphine girard
bonjour d'un film de public sénat qui
suit évidemment ce texte depuis hier et
la déclaration du premier ministre
un texte qui a été voté à l'assemblée on
le sait avec une vingtaine de députés
socialistes qui n'ont pas voté ce texte
alors qui va voter et comment au sénat
qu'est ce qui va se passer
michael on le sait déjà puisque sans
surprise malgré l'invitation
hier du premier ministre jean marc
ayrault à la à l'adresse des sénateurs
de faire un choix d'avenir en ratifiant
ce texte est bien les nonistes du sénat
campent sur leurs positions dans la
principale difficulté ici pour le
gouvernement ne vient pas des
socialistes même il n'y a qu'une seule
nonistes on le sait c'est la sénatrice
de paris mano marie noëlle lienemann
mais la difficulté pour le gouvernement
vient de ses traditionnels alliés
en effet lé 20 sénateurs que comptent le
groupe communiste ne voterons pas ce
texte 12 10 des 12 sénateurs que
comptent les groupes écologistes
partageront leurs votes rentrer à votre
contre ou une abstention et puis même
chez les radicaux de gauche
il faudra compter avec le vote contre de
jean pierre chevènement il a expliqué ce
matin en défendant une motion mais aussi
robert hue donc ancien ministre et
sénateur communiste qui a rejoint le
groupe rdc au sénat pourraient
s'abstenir ou encore le sénateur
pierre-yves collombat alors la gauche a
beau faire ses comptes tout à l'heure il
faudra compter avec les voix de la
droite pour faire passer ce texte est
une poésie de position politique
sensible délicate inconfortable pour le
gouvernement mais une position que
savoure la droite sénatoriale c'est
françois zocchetto je cite qui a dit
laissez nous apprécier cette instance
est juste
mesure d'hab il rhône isère en voyant la
majorité ses propres failles d'un terne
merci beaucoup delphine évidemment vous
nous ferez vivre ce vote un peu plus
tard dans l'après-midi sur notre antenne
nous avons entendu à la vie d'alice déjà
premièrement dans l'opposition se
réjouit d'avoir voté et de vous embêter
un petit peu et puis chez vous chez vos
alliés ben c'est très embêtant aussi
parce qu'il y en a qui ne vont pas voter
ou s'abstenir est ce que c'est une
victoire ou une défaite à la vie d'alice
bas c'est tout sauf une surprise parce
que les votes elle qui viennent d'être
rappelés sont des votes attendus
jamais le gouvernement ne s'est donné
comme objectif d'avoir une majorité de
gauche
ici au sénat pourtant on a entendu
jamais d'accord je jamais personne n'a
jamais dit que nous aurions une majorité
de gauche au sénat pour soutenir ce
texte est une réalité politique
d'ailleurs tout à fait incontournable
tu vois pas comment on aurait pu un
moment donné imaginer qui s'ignoraient
une majorité de gauche pour tous tenu de
la position connue et respectable et
dans tous les cas attendus notamment du
groupe nouveaux communistes mais aussi
aussi des verts donc c'est sans surprise
alain vidalies vous avez dit c'est pas
une surprise pourtant est-ce que ça a
été une surprise la vingtaine de députés
qui ont voté contre ce texte à
l'assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous avez été surpris cette
fois pas été surpris et j'ai été déçu
bien sûr parce que mon objectif c'est
ken et 0 mais 20 sur 297
proportionnellement d'ailleurs il ya eu
plus de députés de droite qui ont voté
contre que deux députés que des députés
socialistes
mais enfin vincee 22 trop n'a essayé
j'ai essayé jusqu'au bout
effectivement d'arriver à une autre
solution enfin l'objectif là il était
annoncé
c'était que nous ayons une majorité de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale pour
soutenir l'approbation du traité et cet
objectif il a été rempli on le comprend
bien la vie d'alice mais vous-même et
bernard cazeneuve vous avez essayé vous
avez tous fait vous avez vu ce qu'on
appelle les nonistes ceux qui votent non
vous avez vu ce qu'ils voulaient
s'abstenir n'a autre beaucoup entendu
parler également du groupe des verts
on sait qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
polémiques finalement c'est un petit
échec ou pas non c'est pas un petit
échec parce que vous ignorez que les
échecs alors vous ignorer complètement
quelle était la donne de départ avait
expliqué mais la moitié la moitié de
nouveaux députés
beaucoup de députés dont on ne savait
pas exactement quelle était la position
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on est
parti d'assez loin que et que le
résultat était celui qu'on espérait dans
l'est dans les derniers jours je vous
entends bien la vie d'alice
on imagine que au départ il y avait
beaucoup plus de personnes de députés
qui auraient voté non quelle arrivée est
un chiffre ou pas il y en avait plus au
départ qu'à l'arrivée naturellement je
vais pas vous donner un chiffre
vous allez faire d'aller faire des
recherches mais je peux vous dire que le
travail remarquable fait par bach
bernard cazeneuve puis le travail
naturel du ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement s'est quand même
retrouvé dans les chiffres je reviens
sur ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure au
sénat et delphine le c'est bien parce
qu'elle travaille évidemment sur toutes
ces questions parlementaires est ensuite
très près ce qui se passe dans les votes
il est beaucoup plus difficile au sénat
de vous faire entendre vous mais une
majorité que de cinq ou six sièges c'est
très bête retrait et 3 est-ce que ça
augure pour d'autres textes également de
problèmes que vous allez rencontrer ici
au sénat naturellement on peut penser
qu'il ya un certain nombre de textes sur
lequel la majorité sénatoriale qui doit
être unie pour constituer des majorités
peut ne pas se trouver au rendez vous
c'est une donnée politique que personne
ne peut ignorer que le gouvernement
n'ignore pas hélas pour le vote qui aura
lieu cet après midi vous avez des
craintes vous avez chiffré vous avez non
on n'a pas de crainte
compte tenu de ce qui a été annoncé à
droite votre avis le traité sera votée
aujourd'hui et c'est pour passer le
scénario qu'on a toujours envisagé qui
va se produire et donc par rapport à ce
que disait delphine tout à l'heure le
nombre de sénateurs qui vont voter non
au niveau on estime à 1 2-10 n 10 est
delphine tout à l'heure non mais dans le
groupe socialiste résultat est assez
remarquable
c'est important pour le gouvernement et
puisqu'il y aura a priori un seul vote
contre après coteaux de la position
prise par le groupe des verts et le
groupe communiste
naturellement il manquera des voix dans
la majorité sénatoriale est dans tous
les cas dans la majorité présidentielle
comment vous expliquez que hier à
l'assemblée nationale cette fois la loi
organique a rassemblé plus de wii que le
traité que le vote du traité lui-même
c'est une question qu'il faudrait
d'abord poser à ceux qui ont à la fois
voté non au traité oui à la loi
organique
en réalité je pense qu'ils ont pris acte
du fait que le traité avait été voté et
c'est l'explication qui l'on donnait en
indiquant qu'à partir du moment où ce
vote intervenu et a posteriori il
n'avait aucune raison de s'opposer à la
loi organique est en elle même d'une
certaine façon la première étape avant
le vote de la loi de finances et qu' il
rejoignait de ce point de vue là la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale alors
tout à l'heure à la vie d'alice vous
parliez évidemment de l'opposition qui a
voté avec vous pour ce texte
évidemment c'est la suite logique de ce
qui s'était passé sous nicolas sarkozy
et du gouvernement de françois fillon je
vous propose d'écouter philippe marini
sénateur de l'oise qui s'exprimait hier
à la tribune
je pense que la majorité sénatoriale
comme le gouvernement le développent des
argumentaires très complexe pour mieux
enrober le changement que l'exercice du
pouvoir induit tout à fait naturellement
mais et je suis inquiet quand je lis
certains commentaires
à commencer par ceux du du premier
ministre cette insistance que l'on met à
nous dire par exemple que le traité qui
nous est soumis et même plus souple que
le traité de maastricht
cette insistance que l'on met dans tous
les commentaires
à montrer qu'il y aura des marges de
manoeuvre plus importante n'est ce pas
une tentation qui se fait jour de
reprendre les pratiques du passé à
savoir s'arranger sur le plan national
et par les européens à bruxelles par les
français à paris or c'est quand même
bien ce que je le répète les
gouvernements successifs ont fait
pendant tant et tant d'années et ce qui
mine la confiance je pense que seuls
deux programmes de stabilité
ceux des deux dernières années ont été
au rendez vous de la réalité tous les
autres depuis l'époque où l'on a
commencé à faire des problèmes de
stabilité et laurent fabius était
ministre de l'économie et des finances
tous les autres étaient en décalage
systématique et volontaire avec la
réalité
ben vous venez d'entendre philippe
marini c'était hier ici au sénat pendant
évidemment la discussion avant ce vote
que vous pourrez suivre évidemment sur
notre antenne
alain vidalis il ya un vrai problème
c'est à dire que de fond cette fois sur
le texte lui-même certains ont peur
vous savez de cette règle d'or de cette
fameuse règle d'or qui devait être
imposée dans la constitution qui ne sera
pas finalement est ce que disait tout à
l'heure à la marine dit philippe marini
c'est que c'est pas le même texte n'aura
pas la même voix à bruxelles que la voix
qu'on pouvait avoir ici à l'assemblée ou
au sénat
franchement c'est un discours assez
étonnant quand il lit il ya eu que deux
vrais programmes de stabilité ceux des
dernières années je veux bien qu'il
plaît qui prêche pour sa paroisse je
veux simplement lui faire observer que
ça a été sanctionné par le suffrage
universel et qu'en démocratie a qu'une
seule règle c'est que c'est le suffrage
universel qui tranchent chic entre les
deux le peuple français a choisi une
autre politique
deuxièmement est-ce qu'il s'est rien
passé depuis l'élection présidentielle a
bruissé passer l'élection présidentielle
c'est qu'il semble ignorer et
deuxièmement il s'est passé le sommet
européen et à la suite du sommet
européen un changement très important
celui du comportement de la banque
centrale européenne sur les marchés
est ce que il ya un lien entre
l'élection présidentielle l'action de
françois hollande ce qui s'est passé au
sommet européen et ce changement
naturellement nous pensons que oui dans
tous les cas c'est pas sous l'air de
monsieur marini si j'ose dire ces choses
là se sont passées mais bien après mais
vous entendez un petit peu ce qui se
passe aussi dans votre majorité que ce
soit le front de gauche ou les verts il
dit à la croissance on n'a pas entendu
parler c'était but est le même puisque
celui nicolas sièges sur sept on
l'entend depuis des semaines et la
question quand la question qu'on leur
pose est exactement la même
ceux qui étaient contre le traité avant
l'élection présidentielle emirates
contre le traité après c'est qu'il
considère qu'il ne s'est rien passé
c'est à dire que c'est comme si françois
hollande n'avait rien fait et bien tous
ceux qui soutiennent françois hollande
considère qu'au contraire il ya eu un
changement un changement au sommet du
mois de juin changements cet été et que
c'est ce changement qui aujourd'hui nous
amène à a voté pour ce texte
la question sur ce thème voulait pas
poser tout à l'heure il a gardé pour la
fin
est ce que ceux qui ont voté non vont
être sanctionnés c'est pas une question
qui évidemment relève de la compétence
du gouvernement c'est une question qui
relève de la compétence des groupes
exclusivement éventuellement du parti ça
pour exister ne sais pas nous ne sais
pas vous de récession sur cette question
c'est clair
d'accord il ya un autre débat qui agite
en ce moment un petit peu la classe
politique on va vous laisser partir
juste après parce que vous vous devez
aller dans l'hémicycle c'est sur le
mariage des couples homosexuels
on sait que le débat aura lieu au
conseil des ministres le texte va
arriver le 31 21
après ici au sénat et à l'assemblée et
au sénat
vous entendez un petit peu dans les
rangs de l'opposition c'est mr cette
fronde des maires qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
écoutez je pense que c'est le suffrage
universel chez des élus de la république
qui décideront c'est une réforme
importante elle était dans le programme
qu'a présenté le candidat françois
hollande elle sera dans le programme
appliqué par le président de la
république françois hollande alors on a
posé la question à des sénateurs maires
pour savoir ce qu'ils en pensaient de
cette ronde et de cette loi je vous
propose de les écouter le droit de
retrait est un droit tellement grave que
pour l'instant je ne les pas envisager
maintenant si collectivement dans une
sorte de protestation nationale
ce mouvement étaient mis en oeuvre par
des milliers de mères moment là je me
prononcerai je pense qu'il faut être
très prudent parce que encore une fois
le maire n'est pas simplement le
représentant la collectivité il est le
représentant de l'état et donc il est
chargé d'appliquer la loi et la loi
qu'elle soit bonne qu'elle soit mauvaise
heureusement on est quand même tenu par
un certain nombre de règles mois
j'exercerai d'une manière ou d'une autre
mon droit de retrait je serai
complètement hors la loi et je
l'assumerai d'une façon ou d'une autre
mais je refuserais précisément d'assumer
cela vous l'entendez parmi ces réactions
diverses réactions diverses façons de
voir les choses et d'appliquer ou pas la
loi
si vous étiez maire vous feriez quoi je
l'appliquerais puisque j'ai une loi que
j'appelle de mes voeux depuis longtemps
mais la question est plus grave que ça
et ça c'est une vraie question de fond
sur lequel il faut s'attarder une petite
minute qu'entendre des mers tirs
j'appliquerai pas la loi une certaine
façon je veux exercer mon droit de
retrait distille qui est une notion qui
n'existe pas qui est inventé dans la
circonstance c'est quelqu'un m'explique
ce qu'est le droit de retrait pour ne
pas appliquer la loi
je pense à tous ces gens leur dire une
chose on peut pas tout la semaine
expliqué aux jeunes notamment à ceux qui
sont qui vivent en marche qu'il ya la
loi qui à la république et tout d'un
coup sur cette question là parce qu'elle
vous plaît pas le jour où ça sera la loi
ça n'est pas aujourd'hui dire ben moi je
n'appliquerai pas la loi
je crois que d'un point de vue
républicain il devrait réfléchir à ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire dans la
société du message qu'ils envoient aussi
ne veulent pas appliquer la loi
moi je leur dis qu'une seule chose
personne est obligée d'être mère c'est
au maire de montrer l'exemple est ce que
aujourd'hui la pétition qui a eu lieu et
qui évoque un petit peu partout et tout
le monde parle de cette fronde des
maires pour c'est que c'est donc une
erreur de la part des maires
d'opposition
c'est une erreur c'est une faute
politique c'est l'expression d'une
gardisme social assez assez fort il ya
déjà dix pays qui applique ça en europe
pour l'instant c'est pas la loi qu'ils
soient contre cette loi c'est normal et
ça fera partie du débat mais si un jour
ce qu'on espère dans les prochaines
semaines cette loi est votée tout le
monde devra l'appliquer
merci beaucoup alain vidalis on vous
laisse évidemment regagner le rang des
ministres
vous le voyez sur ces images le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel vient
de partir du cabinet du départ c'est
vous venez de voir il ya quelques
instants il se dirige donc vers
l'hémicycle
il va prendre place dans quelques
secondes sur le plateau pour ses
traditionnelles questions d'actualité en
ce jeudi d'octobre
évidemment il y aura un certain nombre
de questions sur le plan économique
c'est également sur le plan de la
justice sur la sécurité
nous allons tout de suite en séance
bonne séance à tous on se retrouve pour
à vers 16h pour refaire la séance à tout
à l'heure
quelques secondes de retard vous voyez
jean pierre bel va arriver il s'installe
progressivement les rangs commencent
également à se remplir voilà bonne
séance à tous
à tout à l'heure
la séance est reprise mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente
la parole est un monsieur vraiment
valent pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social européen merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie le groupe rdse auquel
j'appartiens est très attentif au
développement des énergies renouvelables
et l'autre position déjà exprimée à
plusieurs reprises dans cette enceinte
est connu l'indépendance énergétique de
la france est un objectif incontournable
qui doit reposer sur la recherche et le
développement des deux filières
d'excellence que sont le nucléaire et
les énergies renouvelables
à l'issue de la conférence
environnementale d'il ya quelques
semaines le gouvernement a présenté une
feuille de route pour la transition
écologique elle peut se résumer à cette
phrase forte les énergies renouvelables
et les nouvelles technologies de
l'énergie offrent l'opportunité d'une
nouvelle révolution industrielle et
sociétales et le groupe rdse il souscrit
entièrement nous savons madame la
ministre qu'elle est le lourd héritage
que vous avez à gérer en matière
d'énergies renouvelables et de l'état
dramatique des filières photovoltaïques
éoliennes avec des fermetures d'usinés
et des suppressions de l'emploi nous
savons aussi que vous travaillez à
l'élaboration d'une véritable politique
de relance de ces filières mais pour
autant il y a urgence à traiter ces
dossiers en attente et à prendre des
décisions qui dans cette phase de
transition vont permettre de sauver ce
qui peut encore l'être
en effet sur un territoire beaucoup
d'entreprises nous font part de leur
grande difficulté elle se heurte à une
politique tarifaire inadapté à des
procédures administratives est
extrêmement lourdes et complexes à des
délais excessifs enfin à des retards
dans l'exécution des récents appels
l'offre qui sont incompatibles avec leur
survie économique en un mot ces
entreprises n'ont aucune visibilité à
court terme sur leur avenir
nos concitoyens nos entrepreneurs qui
ont pourtant pris le risque de se lancer
dans ces nouvelles filières
et les élus locaux qui ont fait le choix
de les soutenir mérite mieux
ils sont en droit d'attendre des mesures
concrètes de sauvegarde de ces filières
aussi madame la ministre ma question est
la suivante
que comptez-vous faire face à ses
problèmes dans les semaines qui viennent
j'ose dire dans les jours qui viennent
pour redresser cette situation
merci merci pour vous répondre madame
delphine batho ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateur raymond vall monsieur le
président je vous remercie de votre
question qui me permet de souligner
effectivement la nécessité de prendre
des mesures d'urgence des mesures qui
relèvent de ce que j'appelle le
patriotisme écologiques pour répondre
aux attentes de filières industrielles
qui souffrent dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables
vous le savez la france est engagée dans
une politique de transition énergétique
avec les engagements qu'a pris le
président de la république qui doivent
aboutir en 2025 y avoir une évolution de
notre mix électrique cela doit passer
par la montée en puissance de ces
énergies renouvelables nous aurons très
bientôt l'ouverture du débat sur la
transition énergétique qui permettra de
mettre en place un cadre stable et
durable pour la durée du quinquennat qui
permettra aux entreprises d'avoir la
prévisibilité la visibilité dont elles
ont besoin pour orienter leurs
investissements et leurs stratégies ceci
dit vous avez raison de dire qu'il faut
prendre des mesures d'urgence c'est
pourquoi nous avons annoncé des mesures
d'urgence pour la filière solaire
d'abord avec le lancement d'un nouvel
appel d'offres pour les grandes
installations avec aussi la continuation
des appels d'offres pour les moyennes
installations et une
augmentation du tarif de rachat pour le
petit photovoltaïque sachant que ces
mesures donneront lieu à des systèmes de
bonification pour la création de valeur
ajoutée sur le territoire national
puisque notre but c'est de soutenir les
entreprises qui créent des emplois en
france et c'est un aspect très important
du soutien des mesures de soutien à la
filière solaire
nous avons aussi nous sommes en train de
discuter vous le savez de mesures de
relance de l'énergie éolienne puisque
nous sommes très loin des objectifs du
grenelle de l'environnement
nous sommes aujourd'hui seulement à 6006
870 kilowattheure de mégawattheures par
nom de puissance installée et donc il y
a nécessité là aussi il ya eu un
effondrement des projets d'implantation
d'éoliennes alors que l'énergie éolienne
est assez compétitive et donc ça fait
l'objet des amendements que le
gouvernement a présenté dans la
proposition de loi de françois brottes
pour qu'il y ait des dispositions de
simplification administrative qui
permette qu'il y ait toujours une
consultation des élus locaux une
consultation des citoyens lorsqu'ils y a
des projets d'implantation d'éoliennes
mais qu'il y ait un certain nombre de
deux d'éléments qui simplifie les
procédures administratives pour que ces
projets soient davantage soutenu et vous
avez raison de dire l'énergie éolienne
ces onze mille emplois en france c'est
180 entreprises qui attendent
aujourd'hui des mesures de soutien et
des mesures d'urgence
merci ma part est à présent monsieur
christian favier pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
ma question est ce le ministre s'adresse
autant à vous qu à votre collègue du
budget nous avons vous savez appris avec
stupéfaction par la presse la décision
du gouvernement de ne pas inscrire dans
la loi de programmation budgétaire le
milliard d'euros prévus en dotation à la
société du grand paris pour la
réalisation du grand paris express
cette décision a posé vous le savez
immédiatement une très vive émotion
parmi la population et l'ensemble des
élus locaux maintenue elle constituerait
un très mauvais coup mauvais coup
d'abord pour les millions d'usagers de
la région capitale
confrontez vous le savez chaque jour
à de grandes difficultés pour se
déplacer mauvais coup également pour
l'emploi et la croissance de la région
capitale
si ce projet devait ne plus être
financés ou même retardé ce sera un
véritable choc pour l'économie
francilienne
dès lors à quoi bon évoqué l'idée même
d'une politique régionale ambitieuse
d'aménagement d'environnement de
logements de développement économique
face à des enjeux aussi lourds le
conseil d'administration du syndicat des
transports d'île de france s'est exprimé
hier de façon extrêmement clair et net
en adoptant à l'unanimité toutes
sensibilités politiques rassemblées un
voeu demandant l'inscription de ces
crédits d'ici la fin de l'année dans la
loi de programmation budgétaire
monsieur le ministre comment parler de
pacte de confiance entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
si un tel projet qui a fait l'objet d'un
accord unanime en janvier 2011 entre
l'état la région et tous les
départements d'île de france et est
aujourd'hui remis en cause alors que l'
enquête publique sur le premier tronçon
sud qui va des hauts-de-seine à la
seine-saint-denis qui traverse tout le
val de marne va débuter dans quelques
semaines aussi la question est simple
monsieur le ministre
allez-vous dans la loi de programmation
budgétaire réinscrire le milliard
d'euros manquants et confirmer vos
engagements aux côtés des collectivités
territoriales francilienne en faveur de
la réalisation du métro du grand paris
express dans les délais annoncés
monsieur
les ministres changent et les transports
de la mer de la cloche merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur permettez
moi tout d'abord d'excusés madame cécile
duflot retenue qui m'a demandé de vous
livrer des réponses claires comme elles
le sont d'ailleurs de façon constante
réponse donnée par le gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous le savez le grand
paris est un engagement du président de
la république il a été répété c'est un
engagement qui est celui du gouvernement
et il a été répété le schéma d'ensemble
est un schéma qui unit l'état la région
ile de france
il ne changera pas le tracé les lignes
sera confirmé la localisation des gares
sera maintenu et de laisser planer le
doute peut être de d'accompagner
l'absence de force de démonstrations par
des vociférations n'y changeront rien
c'est un engagement du gouvernement et
pour ce qui est de la réalisation
financière le plan de financement sera
décidé et il reflétera une politique de
priorisation ce qui est vrai pour le
snit dont j'ai la charge
le schéma national des infrastructures
de transport ce qui est vrai pour le
snit est vrai aussi du grand paris où un
certain nombre de promesses ont été
faites il convient maintenant puisque la
charge nous est donnée d'assumer les
responsabilités des engagements des
autres alors nous y mettrons de la
rigueur
nous y mettrons de la méthode et nous
verrons point par point ligne par ligne
gare par gare les conditions financières
qui nous permettront de mener à bien ce
projet qui n'est pas simplement un
projet de transport qui est un projet
d'aménagement du territoire d'équilibré
du territoire et qui permettra
d'apporter des réponses au quotidien des
franciliens
vous le savez cet engagement sur la
qualité des transports sur l'aménagement
du territoire sur les réponses au
quotidien pour ce qui est une attente de
des franciliens est une préoccupation
constante du gouvernement
cécile duflot l'a dit la répéter et je
me fais
réaffirmé je suis désolé messieurs les
sénateurs de ce côté de l'hémicycle
peut-être êtes-vous privé de la parole
de madame duflot ce que vous voulez dans
cet état et je ne fais que répéter me
faire ce porte parole pour dire que
c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement
et lorsqu'il sera nécessaire d'inscrire
le fameux milliard permettant de
poursuivre celui ci sera maintenu il est
aujourd'hui envisagé pour 2015 s'il doit
intervenir avant il interviendra avant
et le gouvernement assumera ses
responsabilités et répondra à vos
attentes
merci madame marie annick duchêne pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale la
multiplication d'incidents dans les
établissements scolaires l'évolution
préoccupante de ce phénomène et d'actes
qui relève pour moi plus du code pénal
que du simple fait divers devient une
vraie question de société
dans un contexte de banalisation de la
violence et de rejet de toute forme
d'autorité prévenir et lutter contre
cette violence en milieu scolaire est
une des conditions essentielles de la
refondation de l'école ce n'est que dans
un climat apaisé que tous les acteurs
pourront travailler en concertation dans
le respect des compétences dévolues à
chacun et dans un climat de confiance
mutuelle la refondation de l'école
monsieur mini ce n'est ces citera vous
le savez beaucoup plus que la réforme
des rythmes scolaires dans le rapport de
concertation je n'ai quasiment rien
trouvé sauf un peu page 45
qui permettent de croire que vous vous
donnerez les moyens de relever ce défi
essentiel
rien qui laisse entrevoir des pistes
d'action pour faire reculer la violence
en milieu scolaire
monsieur le ministre
où sont les propositions et les
orientations du gouvernement pour
assurer la sécurisation des
établissements redonner du sens à la
prévention à l'éducation et aux
sanctions scolaires pour réintroduire
enfin la fonction d'autorité
m merci monsieur vincent peillon
ministre annulation nationale monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame là la sénatrice vous
avez raison est d'attirer l'attention de
la représentation nationale et du
gouvernement sur des phénomènes qui nous
touche tous
et dans le fond sont des blessures pour
notre république et en même temps pour
la transmission que nous voulons opérer
vers les plus jeunes
nous sommes évidemment les adultes car
j'entends souvent les discours sur la
jeunesse les premiers responsables de
cet état de fait et c'est ce qui a
justifié que le président de la
république ait décidé de faire de
l'école et de la jeunesse
la priorité non seulement parce que
c'est une catégorie mais parce que c'est
la france de demain et que nous voyons
bien dans la transmission d'un certain
nombre de valeurs dont l'ordre dont
l'autorité
nous avons ces dernières années failli
vous me dites et c'est à tort car je
crois pas que c'est un sujet de
polémiques en tous cas je ne le souhaite
pas la concertation n'a pas abordé ce
sujet la concertation étaient libres
d'aborder les sénateurs et sénatrices y
participer les sujets qu'elle voulait
mais le gouvernement aborde avec
beaucoup de résolutions
d'abord vous le savez sans doute nous
avons créé un nouveau métier c'était la
demande du président de la république ce
sont les assistants de prévention et de
sécurité
j'entendais une réflexion sur ces bancs
disant encore une commission non 500
emplois nouveaux qui sont déjà en train
d'exercer leurs responsabilités dans les
collèges les plus en difficulté
deuxièmement jamais jamais y compris
après dix ans vous étiez aux
responsabilités le terme violence
scolaire n'avait été inscrit
dans les directions de l'éducation
nationale j'ai demandé la création il y
à un mois et s'est fait d'une délégation
à la lutte à la prévention et à la lutte
contre les violences scolaires qui s'est
chargé non seulement de nous les faire
connaître
mais de nous outiller pour lutter contre
cette violence et former les professeurs
à un pouvoir réagir mieux en travaillant
d'ailleurs avec les services de justice
et avec les services de police
jamais je n'ai remis en cause vous
l'aurez noté y compris les équipes
mobiles de sécurité et le délégué qui a
été nommé a été auditionné par
l'assemblée nationale
je vous conseille de faire la même chose
il a bien indiqué que dans les missions
qu'ils se confier c'était aussi que l'on
travaille mieux ces établissements
sensibles avec les équipes de sécurité
enfin je voudrais vous dire la chose
suivante chaque fois qu'un enseignant a
été agressé pour la première fois j'ai
utilisé l'article 40
il est inadmissible que des personnels
de service public ça vaut aussi pour les
élèves mais dans ma responsabilité
puisse éprouver la moindre crête a au
nom de nous tous transmettre les valeurs
de la connaissance et de la république
je souhaite que tous les français se
rassemblent autour de l'école tous les
français doivent se rassembler autour de
cet impératif
retrouvez l'autorité et je finirai en
vous disant la chose suivante nous avons
besoin d'adultes dans les établissements
nous avons besoin de recréer la
confiance nous avons besoin d'enseigner
la morale laïque
nous avons besoin aussi dans nos
comportements de faire preuve
d'exemplarité
merci monsieur yves pozzo di borgo dans
le cou baignant centriste et
républicaine
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mme asma
testions s'adressait plutôt prémunissent
mais comme il n'est pas là je sais que
ceux qui venaient même répondre la
mondialisation implique le développement
d'une économie entreprenariale de la
connaissance et se caractérise par la
puissance d'une urbanisation
ce qui fait que les grandes villes sont
devenus le moteur essentiel de
l'économie mondiale les villes-monde new
york londres tokyo paris avec les
nouvelles entrantes shanghai sao paulo
et autres sont devenus la référence de
cette mondialisation
or paris est une petite ville de 2
millions d'habitants
enfermé dans son périphérique
par contre par contre par ile de france
est une ville monde audigy % de la
population française fournissent 20 9%
du pib français dont 22% sont utilisés
par les franciliens le reste étant
distribué dans les autres régions
françaises le président nicolas sarkozy
en avait pris acte dans son discours du
29 avril 2009
la loi du 3 juin 2010 sur la grande
boucle des transports parisiens en était
le premier pas pour accompagner pour
conforter les pôles stratégiques
d'ile-de-france et conforter et assurer
le développement économique du pays et
de l'europe
et ceci avec un consensus général des
acteurs politiques économiques et
sociaux cette région même si à l'époque
de collègues du groupe communiste et
socialiste n'avait pas voté cette loi
or en dehors d'une allusion du président
de la république le jo son investiture à
l'hôtel de ville qui a parlé
discrètement d'une métropole parisienne
nous avons été très surpris que vendredi
dernier dans son discours supposé
fondateur sur les collectivités
territoriales
pas un mot n'a été dit sur la nécessité
de construire le grand paris
ajoutez à cela l'absence du premier
milliard sur le grand paris dans la loi
de financement pour 2013 alors même que
311 millions d'euros de taxes spéciales
ont déjà été pré le
et sur les entreprises consigne n pour
financer ce projet sans compter la part
que les franciliens paix sur leurs
impôts locaux
vous comprendrez monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre va y
répondre
madame la ministre qui n'est pas là que
les élus franciliens
quand beaucoup de vos amis politiques
dont le président de la région lui-même
s'interroge sur l'absence de réflexion
et de réflexion et de vision ce dossier
majeur
ce gouvernement est une vision du grand
paris quelle est elle
la réponse en deux minutes un peu courte
nous avons besoin d'être rassuré
monsieur frédéric cuvillier ministre
chargé des transports de la mer et de la
pêche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs puisque vous avez
besoin d'être assuré je vais reprendre
la démonstration une 6ème fois pour vous
dire combien le gouvernement et madame
duflot ministre chargée de l'égalité des
territoires est attentive à la réalité
la concrétisation le réalisme dans la
réalisation de ce grand paris en effet
vous avez replacer paris dans un
contexte de compétitivité internationale
mais notre grand paris tel que nous
voulons le faire et nous le ferons et le
souhait du gouvernement de faire le
grand paris des habitants le faire le
grand paris qui était bien évidemment
source d'attractivité nationale voire
internationale mais qui soit en
situation de pouvoir répondre aux
réalités du quotidien le grand paris qui
est le nôtre c'est du grand paris de
l'emploi c'est le grand paris de
l'attractivité économique
c'est le grand paris du logement et
notamment du logement social répondant
ainsi au voeu à la volonté du président
de la république et du premier ministre
c'est le grand paris de l'égalité des
territoires pour éviter que nous ayons
les hommes de cette région ce soit
enclavée c'est le grand paris de
l'efficacité c'est le grand paris de la
solidarité de l'innovation bref c'est le
grand paris tel que nous le rendrons
crédible car dans ce que vous nous dites
avec ce que vous nous léguer ce que vous
nous laissez c'est un grand paris qui
n'est qu'une succession de promesses et
de projets et nous nous limitons pas au
projet nous sommes dans la
concrétisation
il nous a été indiqué j'ai répondu à
l'instant concernant le miam et vous
même dit qu'il y a des crédits qui ont
été levées c'est à dire que dès demain
nous devons être dans la réalisation de
ce qui l attendent des franciliens ce
qui est leur questionnement ce qui est
l'anxiogène le coup de caractère
anxiogène des transports notamment
et nous le ferons parce que nous avons
la volonté d'expertisé d'analysé et ce
qui a été la méthode pour le smic et la
méthode pour le grand paris de rendre
crédible ligne par ligne réalisation par
réalisation l'ensemble des projets qui
ont été simplement un amoncellement de
promesses électorales à une période
propice
ce qui était promesses électorales
deviendra concrétisation d'une volonté
ambitieuse et solidaire merci je passe
la parole à présent à madame kalliopi
angot et da pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur la
presse s'est fait écho il ya une semaine
environ du souhait du gouvernement de
revenir sur les critères pénalisant
introduite par le président de ministre
de l'intérieur en matière de
naturalisation je salue évidemment la
détermination affichée de la nouvelle
majorité d'affirmer une volonté forte
d'intégration par l'accès à la
nationalité française
les éléments relayés par la presse font
notamment état de la suppression du qcm
de connaissances générales cette épreuve
dans tous les sens du terme est souvent
perçu comme humiliante par nos
concitoyens inspirant à la nationalité
française
cependant rien n'est dit sur
l'obligation faite depuis le 1er janvier
2012 par tous les candidats à la
nationalité française de présenter un
document certifiant leur niveau de
langue
cette mesure prise par l'ancienne
majorité leur impose en effet de fournir
un diplôme ou une attestation certifiant
qu'ils ont acquis le niveau b1 orale en
langue française cette dernière
attestation est délivrée par un
organisme labellisés
fl é français langue d'intégration ou un
organisme agréé par le ministère de
l'intérieur
à l'étranger elle s'obtient auprès des
alliances françaises ou des instituts
français au delà du coût que représente
cette démarche elle pose également des
problèmes particuliers concernant les
conjoints de français résidant à
l'étranger
a fortiori dans les pays francophones il
est ainsi aberrant d'être obligé de
produire un document certifiant notre
niveau de langue lorsque l'on est
originaire d'un état qui compte le
français parmi ces langues nationales je
ne peux m'empêcher d'illustrer mes
propos avec l'exemple du cameroun où je
résidais depuis 25 ans avant de
rejoindre les grands du sénat au mois de
juillet dernier
de la même manière comment réagirions
nous si un postulant français à la
nationalité belge sujets d'actualité se
voyait imposer de fournir la preuve de
son niveau de langue française
s'il est évident que maîtriser la langue
d'un pays constitue indéniablement un
vecteur d'intégration cela ne doit pas
se transformer en parcours d'obstacles
onéreux et humiliant dès lors
monsieur le ministre jose je souhaite
savoir quel est le sort réservé au
certificat de niveau de langue
par ailleurs les améliorations prévues
quant au droit à la nationalité corsair
ne romps l acquisition par déclaration
relative aux conjoints de français ou
seront elles cantonné aux demandes de
naturalisation et réintégration
enfin pourriez-vous également nous
éclairer sur le calendrier envisagé
je vous en remercie merci monsieur
manuel valls ministre de l'intérieur ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice ces deux
dernières années l'accès à la
nationalité française a été entravée et
empêcher et cette politique a produit
les résultats que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui que rappelait l'autre jour
le premier ministre une baisse du nombre
de naturalisations de 40% entre 2011 et
demi à mai 2002 ces obstacles qui n'ont
jamais fait l'objet d'un débat ont
touché notamment les étrangers installez
régulièrement et depuis longtemps en
france parfaitement inséré dans la
société qui ont fait le choix de devenir
français
notre volonté
et de changer cette donne de refaire de
l'accès à la nationalité
un moteur de l'intégration pour cela
nous travaillons à propos d'une
circulaire qui devrait être adressée aux
préfets dans quelques jours pour revenir
sur les critères les plus discriminants
retenons quatre idées la première c'est
que la méthode du questionnaire à choix
multiples relatifs à la connaissance de
l'histoire et de la culture et la
société française sera abandonné
deuxièmement concernant les tests
j'estime évidemment que la connaissance
du français est évidemment un facteur
d'intégration tout à fait essentiel le
niveau exigé sera maintenue mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce niveau qui
peut être discriminant mais la façon
dont il est évalué et la prise en compte
des conditions spécifiques de certaines
personnes enfin nous allons également
ciblé les critères l'origine de la
majeure partie des refus comme le
critère de l'insertion professionnelle
et j'évoquerai également dans cette
circulaire et c'est le quatrième point
le traitement réservé aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans ayant effectué tout au
parti de lorsque l'arrêté en france
ainsi que le cas des médecins étrangers
bref madame la sénatrice je souhaite
mener un travail ambitieux en matière de
naturalisation il s'agit pas d'engager
des polémiques il ne s'agit pas d'ouvrir
un débat absurde sur la nationalité on
appelle des mots à l'assemblée nationale
de pierre mazeaud qui nous avait
conseillé il ya deux ans de ne pas
ouvrir ce débat qui est néfaste mais de
faire en sorte que ceux qui veulent être
français le soient dans de bonnes
conditions et que nous soyons fiers
parce que c'est le message de la france
d'accueillir de nouveaux français
merci la parole d'ing
monsieur michel berson pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés nom ou ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
les conditions de vie des étudiants sont
des facteurs clés de leur réussite à
l'université or les étudiants vivent
aujourd'hui une véritable galère pour se
loger pénurie de places en résidences
universitaires chambres louées à des
prix exorbitants le désengagement de
l'état depuis dix ans dans la
construction de résidences
universitaires le comportement parfois
abusif de certains bailleurs privés les
agissements de certaines agences
immobilières vendant des listes souvent
factices d'appartements à louer explique
cette situation insupportable vécue par
un étudiant sur deux je dis bien un
étudiant sur deux en effet la france
compte un peu plus de 2 millions
d'étudiants
mais il n'ya que 165 mille places en
cité universitaire 150000 en résidences
privées et 700 mille étudiants vivent
chez leurs parents se sont donc bien un
million d tido c'est-à-dire un étudiant
sur deux qui cherchent à se loger ces
dernières années les plans se sont
succédé mais la pénurie de logements
étudiants à perdurer dans le plan sio2
2004 le gouvernement avait pris
l'engagement de créer 5000 logements
étudiants parents et d'en réhabiliter
7000 moins de 60% de ces objectifs ont
été atteints résultat seuls 8% des
étudiants bénéficient d'un logement
gérés par le crous dans le plan campus
sur les treize mille logements annoncé
aucun aucun n'a été réalisée quant au
passeport logement qui devait faciliter
l'accès des étudiants au parc privé
cette poudre à sept contrats ont été
signés dès lors les loyers de 450 à 700
euros par mois pour un studio pèse de
plus en plus lourd dans le budget des
étudiants
il représente 40 à 45 % de leurs
dépenses
conséquence 50 % des étudiants sont
obligés d'avoir une activité salariée
pendant leurs études
ces chiffres sont accablants pour les
anciens gouvernements
madame le ministre le président de la
république a fait de l'éducation et de
la jeunesse
la priorité de son action alors comment
le gouvernement tente il répondre à
l'attenté des étudiants qui veulent tout
simplement se loger dignement à des prix
raisonnables pour pouvoir étudier et
pour pouvoir réussir
merci madame geneviève fioraso ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs c'est un triste
monsieur le sénateur michel berson avant
de répondre à votre question de ce
sénateur permettez moi tout d'abord de
partager le plaisir que nous avons
depuis mardi d'avoir un prix nobel de
chimie français en la personne du
professeur serge haroche
en plus devrais-je dire car c'est le
cinquième prix nobel de physique en
france au cours de ces dix dernières
années
cette qualité de la science doit
beaucoup à la qualité de notre
enseignement secondaire supérieur
primaire secondaire supérieur et à la
qualité de notre recherche la réussite
des étudiants de tous les étudiants et
la priorité de ce gouvernement car
toutes les études vous l'avait bien dit
sénateurs berson toutes les études
montrent l'impact des conditions de vie
sur l'échec en premier cycle
elle montre aussi que la démocratisation
de l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur
est en panne avec -2 9 % de jeunes issus
de milieux modestes au niveau du master
le logement vous l'avait pointé à juste
titre est pour beaucoup dans la
dégradation des conditions de vie des
étudiants qui par conséquent exercent
une activité professionnelle ou plutôt
devrait dire des petits boulots
ce qui évidemment aubert leurs chances
de réussite notamment dans le premier
cycle à l'université
en région parisienne les loyers ça nous
a été dit ce matin à thierry repentin
moi même qui est une ensemble à
l'université de cergy avec certains
d'entre vous en région parisienne donc
le montant des loyers atteint jusqu'à
70% du budget mensuel d'un étudiant
comment dans ces conditions
peut-il réussir ses études à lyon lille
aix bordeaux parmi d'autres
agglomérations tension le budget atteint
effectivement de 40 à 50% comme vous
l'avez dit du budget mensuel et les
difficultés à trouver un logement
pénalise en particulier les jeunes issus
de milieux modestes et les jeunes venant
de l'étranger nous cite vous citez
justement le plan ciot qui a échoué dans
ses objectifs ou l'opération campus avec
là aussi un échec patent
quatre ans après son lancement aucun
chantier lancé aucune demande de permis
de construire déposés alors que les 13
projets retenus des mythes les 13
projets annoncés en 2007
prévoyez treize mille logements la
réalité sur le terrain j'y viens soyez
patient j'y viens la réalité sur le
terrain
on le voit est bien différente des
effets d'annoncé
sans du gouvernement précédent avec des
milliards toujours annoncé survendu
médiatiquement recyclées mais jamais
dépensé pour rattraper ce retard qui
pénalise la réussite étudiante le
président de la république s'est engagé
sur un objectif clair quarante mille
logements en cinq ans alors nous mettons
les bouchées doubles en utilisant avec
ma collègue ministre du logement
la mobilisation du foncier public met à
disposition des collectivités locales
nous voulons faciliter la construction
de logements étudiants en inscrivant six
mille logements par an dans le cadre des
150 mille logements sociaux qui seront
construits nous changeons de méthode
radicalement c'est bien vous intéresser
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
incluant et en nous associant
collectivités territoriales
ce qui n'avait jamais été fait dans le
précédent quinquennat le projet de loi
de finances prévoit de multiplier par
cinq
nos ados logement des opérations
recensant 24 mille logements 24 mille
logements nous ont ils devront déjà été
identifiés pour le logement collectif et
social nous regardons aussi le logement
privé
pour cela nous allons améliorer les
choses par l'encadrement des loyers
nous allons aussi instaurer un passeport
locatif étudiants qui remplace ça
agréablement le fiasco de mon
prédécesseur qu'effectivement à
contractualiser cet accord en un an et
demi alors que dans les régions
alors que dans les régions aquitaine et
midi pyrénées cimes il comptera six
mille contrats sur une initiative
régionale intelligente et raisonnables
ont été conclus merci madame le ministre
juste un mot la vie étudiante et la
réussite de leur parcours bénéficieront
d'un budget en hausse jeudi
c'est un effort qui illustre d'entre eux
priorité nationale en faveur de la
jeunesse de l'enseignement d'éducation
aussi la parole à madame fabienne keller
et le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
s'ils l'acceptent conjointement à
monsieur le ministre du budget jérôme
cahuzac et monsieur le ministre des
affaires européennes
bernard cazeneuve a
à tout passe par le budget je
souhaiterais évoqué ici l'avenir du 11e
contrat triennal pour strasbourg ville
européenne pour la période 2012 2014
ce contrat tient à la mission
particulière chers collègues qui est
celle de strasbourg et qui accueille des
institutions européennes pour le compte
de la france et concerne les obligations
liées à ce statut l'objectif est de
poursuivre une stratégie commune entre
l'état et les collectivités pour
conforter renforcer la place et le rôle
de strasbourg et puis l'autre objectif
plus concret et de soutenir des projets
pour la ville et en particulier les
liaisons aériennes vers les capitales
européennes mais aussi le rayonnement
culturel et la vocation de l'université
de strasbourg qui d'ailleurs a bien
profité du plan campus dans sa mission
de rayonnement international
tous les acteurs politiques et
économiques locaux s'accordent à dire
que le contrat triennal est essentiel
pour la ville le précédent gouvernement
avait travaillé ce dossier et donner un
élan décisif à ce contrat mais
l'échéance électorale nationale n'avait
pas permis sa conclusion après avoir été
reporté à plusieurs reprises depuis mai
la signature de ce contrat tarde cela
crée un climat d'incertitude et
fragilise l'avenir des projets et la
place européenne de strasbourg
cette incertitude est d'autant plus
pénalisante que nous avons eu une très
mauvaise annonce air france klm dont
l'état je rappelle est actionnaire
prévoit de supprimer fermer la ligne
aérienne entre roissy et strasbourg
strasbourg capitale européenne a besoin
d'un soutien clair et d'une présence du
gouvernement
la conclusion rapide de ce contrat sera
un signal positif
messieurs les ministres si je peux me
permettre il n'y a pas d'amour pour
strasbourg
in il n'ya chers collègues que des
preuves d'amour
monsieur le ministre pouvait vous
messieurs les ministres précisé le
calendrier prévu pour la signature de ce
contrat ainsi que des éléments chiffrés
sur le montant de l'enveloppé que vous
envisagez de mobiliser je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre madame monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre chargé des
affaires européennes
madame la sénatrice je vous remercie
pour votre question qui renvoie au rôle
particulier que joue strasbourg comme
capitale européenne et aux moyens dont
strasbourg a besoin pour assumer sa
vocation vous avez eu raison de rappeler
que cette dimension européenne de
strasbourg a toujours conduit l'état à
accompagner cette ville dans le
développement de ses liaisons de
transport et notamment aériennes dans le
développement de ses infrastructures
universitaires et de recherche et dans
un certain nombre de grands événements
également qui contribue au rayonnement
international de la ville dont vous avez
été élu et dont vous êtes représentant
ici au parlement
je voudrais insister sur le fait que
vous avez tout à fait raison d'être
inquiète puisque lorsque nous sommes
arrivés en situation de responsabilité
le contrat triennal dont vous parlez
aurait déjà dû être signée puisque ce
contrat triennal arrivé à expiration au
mois de décembre dernier que vous avez
quitté la responsabilité du pouvoir au
mois de mai dernier et que par
conséquent il aurait été normal que ce
contrat suez arbitrer et signé au moment
où nous sommes arrivés en situation de
responsabilité
ce n'était pas le cas et les arbitrages
qui aurait dû être rendu pour permettre
qu'il fut signée dans les meilleurs
délais n'avaient pas été préparées c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons pris
ce dossier à bras le corps dès notre
arrivée en responsabilité et je vais par
conséquent pouvoir vous donner des
éléments précis comme je les avais donné
d'ailleurs à strasbourg au moment de
l'inauguration de la foire européenne et
qui vous permettront
d'être enfin totalement rassuré le
premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est que les arbitrages sont
rendus que l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales sont reçus dans les jours
qui viennent pour affiner avec eux les
conditions dans lesquelles on procède à
la rédaction définitive de ce contrat de
telle sorte à ce qu'il puisse être signé
dans les meilleurs délais et ses
arbitrages ont été rendus au sein du
gouvernement à la fin du mois de
septembre et par conséquent comme je m'y
étais engagé et qui sont prêts deuxième
élément de réponse pour te concerne la
desserte transports je veux vous
confirmer ici que l'ensemble des
obligations de service public qui
permettent la desserte aérienne de
strasbourg et qui contribue à son
rayonnement européen seront bien
financés dans le cadre du prochain
contrat triennal et que l'ensemble de
ses liaisons aériennes au terme des
appels d'offres qui sont lancés pourront
être financés dans de bonnes conditions
le troisième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister puisque vous l'avez
évoqué c'est la desserte de strasbourg à
partir de roissy
c'est que nous avions pris l'engagement
de recevoir l'ensemble des financeurs
collectivités territoriales de cette
dessert cela a été fait il ya de cela
trois semaines à paris ça a permis
d'engager avec le président d'air france
qui est à la tête d'une entreprise qui
connaît de grosses difficultés depuis
très longtemps de nous faire part de ses
difficultés et malgré tout indiqué qu'il
poursuivrait la discussion avec le
gouvernement et les élus locaux pour
trouver une solution qui permettra nous
l'espérons de maintenir un bon niveau de
desserte aérienne et de transport de
strasbourg contribuant ainsi au
rayonnement européen de cette ville à
laquelle nous sommes très attachés
merci la parole à madame laurence
rossignol pour le groupe socialiste
apparentés
madame la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
vous avez réuni il ya un mois la
première conférence environnementale du
quinquennat et à cette occasion il a été
annoncé que le conseil de la transition
écologique le futur conseil de la
transition écologique s'ouvrir à la
représentation nationale en accueillant
un collège de parlementaires
je tenais à vous dire la satisfaction
avec laquelle nous trace
en blé et particulièrement la commission
du développement durable a accueilli
cette annonce
en ouverture et en clôture de la
conférence environnementale le président
de la république comme le premier
ministre ont prononcé chacun un discours
que l'on peut qualifier de fondateur en
affirmant que la crise écologique
et oui en affirmant que la crise
écologique n'est pas une crise de plus
mais qu'elle est dans la crise globale
et qu'elle se décline sur le terrain
économique social et sanitaire et en
assignant à la france la tâche de porter
un nouveau modèle de développement
le président de la république a donné
pour mission au gouvernement d'organiser
la mutation d'une économie à bout de
souffle
le premier chantier celui de la
transition énergétique pour la
diversification du mix énergétique comme
pour la baisse de consommation pour la
sobriété
il va nous falloir expliquer et
convaincre les usagers comme les acteurs
économiques et en ce qui concerne les
accords avec les acteurs économiques pas
des moindres puisque le président d'edf
a déclaré avant-hier à l'assemblée
nationale que l'augmentation
démographique aboutirait cas par une
race en mécanique de la consommation à
rendre quasiment 20 tous les efforts que
nous pourrions faire en matière de
sobriété énergétique
pourriez vous nous indiquez madame la
ministre
selon quel calendrier quelles méthodes
et avec quel outil vous entendez engager
le débat sur la transition énergétique
et accessoirement comment vous comptez
susciter l'adhésion de notre principale
entreprise énergétique dans laquelle
rappelons le rappelons-lui l'état
détient 85% du capital
merci madame delphine batho ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice laurence rossignol
vous avez raison de dire que le
président de la république comme le
premier ministre ont prononcé lors de la
conférence environnementale un discours
fondateur autour d'une grande ambition
qui est de faire de la france la nation
de l'expérience de l'excellence
environnementale et cette ambition
et cette conférence environnementale
nous n'en sommes qu'au début c'est un
point de départ et la mise en oeuvre de
la feuille de route pour la transition
écologique sur laquelle s'est engagé le
gouvernement qui constituent le
programme de travail du gouvernement
donne lieu à l'heure actuelle un travail
intensif de mes services et je réunirai
le 26 octobre prochain l'ensemble des
partenaires qui ont participé à la
conférence environnementale pour leur
présenter le calendrier d'engagement
précis de la mise en oeuvre de ses
engagements
donc les choses avancent et j'aurai
aussi l'occasion par rapport à
l'organisation du débat national sur la
transition énergétique de réunir en
début de semaine prochaine les
organisations non gouvernementales les
représentants des entreprises pour
répondre à leurs questions et leur
rappeler ce qui a été inscrit dans la
feuille de route en ce qui concerne les
modalités d'organisation de ce débat son
calendrier puisqu'il s'engagera très
rapidement à partir du mois de novembre
prochain
la transition énergétique c'est une
politique qui repose sur deux piliers le
premier c'est la sobriété et
l'efficacité énergétique c'est à dire
une grande politique publique d'économie
d'énergie qui fait défaut aujourd'hui
je rappelle que la france a pris des
engagements au niveau européen de 20%
d'économies d'énergie à l'horizon 2020
et c'est une politique prioritaire parce
qu'elle est bonne pour l'environnement
mais qu'elle est aussi bonne pour le
pouvoir d'achat est bonne pour notre
économie
par exemple lorsqu'on engage un
programme massif de rénovation thermique
des logements anciens ou lorsque l'on
veut mettre en place un bonus malus
c'est à dire une tarification
progressive de l'énergie qui donne un
signal au consommateur ce sera discuté
bientôt devant le sénat le deuxième
pilier c'est le développement des
énergies renouvelables
je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure tout en
garantissant la sécurité
d'approvisionnement la maîtrise du coût
de l'énergie
tous les scénarios seront discutées dans
le débat sur la transition énergétique
est un des blats fédérateur qui devra
mobiliser les citoyens les élus locaux
les entreprises les opérateurs d'énergie
les organisations non gouvernementales
et je n'ai aucun doute que l'opérateur
historique et comme vous l'avez rappelé
une entreprise publique même si elle a
été hélas se transformer en société
anonyme en 2004 s'engagera dans la
transition énergétique il y a même vous
le savez une filiale d'edf qui s'appelle
edf énergies nouvelles et à l'issue du
débat national
le gouvernement présentera un projet de
loi pour la pour l'ate un projet loi de
programmation de la transition
énergétique et c'est la représentation
nationale qui en décidera souverainement
merci la parole est un monsieur gaëtan
gorce
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
et ça monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères ou un le ministre qui pourra
s'exprimer en son nom le 3 février 2008
profitant de la confusion qui régnait à
giannina un détachement militaire arrêté
et fait disparaître
ibni oumar mahamat saleh l'un des
opposants les plus déterminés au régime
d'idriss deby en août de la même année
une commission d' enquête internationale
mettait en cause les plus hautes
autorités de l'état dans cette
disparition qui n'a toujours pas été
éclaircie a exigé une enquête judiciaire
depuis quatre ans le gouvernement
tchadien multiplient les manoeuvres
dilatoires depuis quatre ans avec notre
collègue jean pierre sueur
nous multiplions les initiatives pour
que la vérité soit faite sur cette
affaire j'ai bien compris que le
contexte n'est pas vérité non favorable
dans la mesure où la france travaille
avec le tchad sur le dossier du mali
mais l'alliance n'est pas la
complaisance et la responsabilité que
nous avons au tchad nous crée des
devoirs et de devoir d'agir dans le
respect des principes qui sont les
nôtres en principe notamment le respect
ou des droits de l'homme
aussi au moment où va s'ouvrir le sommet
de la francophonie se veut être
l'occasion pour la france et ses
représentants d'affirmer une volonté
politique différente de celle qui a
prévalu jusqu'à présent et qui s'inspire
justement de l'attachement que nous
portons à la démocratie aussi ne nous
dit pas monsieur madame la ministre que
comme l'ont fait avant vous monsieur
kouchner
madame alliot marie monsieur juppé ne
nous dit pas que le gouvernement
tchadien poursuit ses efforts ce n'est
pas vrai nous avons dit nous plutôt
comment le gouvernement français entend
amener le régime de monsieur idriss déby
à respecter les engagements qu'il a pris
depuis le printemps les opposants
tchadiens la famille
nous-mêmes qui sommes mobilisés sur ce
dossier avons l'espoir qu'un nouveau
gouvernement aura sur ce dossier une
approche plus forte plus clair plus
déterminés cet espoir madame la ministre
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les ronds du
gouvernement ne décevez pas
merci pour vos réponses et madame hélène
conway mouret ministre chargé des
français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gorce veuillez nous
d'abord excusé l'absence de laurent
fabius qui actuellement retenus par un
entretien avec son homologue canadien
comme vous l'avez rappelé le 3 février
l'opposant tchadien ibni oumar mahamat
saleh était arrêté à son domicile par
des militaires tchadiens au moment même
où des violents combats avaient lieu
dans la capitale entre l'armée
tchadienne et du mouvement rebelle venue
du soudan
si l'armée tchadienne a finalement
repoussé cette attaque celle ci a laissé
derrière elle des centaines de morts des
victimes de viols et des destructions
matérielles des violations des droits de
l'homme ont été commises des
personnalités politiques ont été arrêtés
arbitrairement ou menacés seul ibni
oumar sall et n'est pas réapparu à ce
jour une commission d' enquête
internationale a d'abord travaillé afin
de faire toute la lumière sur ces faits
des recommandations d'été est mise dans
un rapport publié le 3 septembre 2008 et
un comité de suivi chargé de veiller à
l'application de ses recommandations a
été créé parmi ces recommandations l'une
concernait le traitement judiciaire de
toutes les volets les violations que
j'ai rappelé depuis quatre ans la france
n'a pas cessé d'intervenir auprès des
autorités tchadiennes avec la communauté
internationale notamment l'union
européenne et l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie pour
que la lumière soit faite sur la
disparation disparition il n'y eu marre
salé et qu'un procès en bonne et due
forme soit rapidement tenu en cela nous
avons agi dans le sens indiqué par la
résolution que l'assemblée nationale
française a voté le 25 mars 2010 à votre
initiative
monsieur le sénateur gorce
notre position est claire et ferme après
avoir soutenu les travaux de la
commission d' enquête internationale
nous encourageons la justice tchadienne
à s'exercer à ce jour il faut constater
que l' enquête judiciaire tchadienne
n'avance que lentement et que les
réponses qui nous sont fournies sont
insuffisantes
nous continuons donc invité les
responsables tchadiens à ne pas négliger
cette affaire qui porte atteinte à
l'image de leur pays
celle ci a été évoquée à de multiples
reprises ces derniers mois avec les plus
hautes autorités tchadiennes
nous mettons notre dialogue politique
avec le tchad au service de la promotion
des droits de l'homme de la bonne
gouvernance et de la démocratie
ces progrès sont lents et le contexte
est difficile
le tchad ne connaît une stabilité
intérieure continue que depuis 2010 mais
nous devons poursuivre nos échanges avec
les autorités tchadiennes en ce sens
merci
la parole est à monsieur bruno
retailleau pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à à
delphine batho le 25 septembre dernier
la cour de cassation a rendu un arrêt
qui va faire date
la cour de cassation a confirmé bien sur
la culpabilité la responsabilité des
pollueurs pour la faire de verica et
elle a aussi reconnu l'existence d'une
notion juridique nouvelle le préjudice
écologique
c'est une victoire pour la vendée mon
département mais aussi pour toutes les
parties civiles prenantes à la faire
pour tous les amoureux de nature c'est
aussi je voudrais le rappeler après 13
années de combat un immense soulagement
un soulagement parce que rien n'était
fait d' avance rien n'était gagné
pour preuve c'est que l'avocat général
avait d'ailleurs requis si j'ose dire
l'annulation pure et simple de toute la
procédure
nous avons été tout près de passer
auprès si j'ose dire d'une forme de
naufrage écologique après la catastrophe
écologique aussi naufrage juridique bien
sûr il s'en est fallu de très très peu
le pire était évité
il faut désormais que nous puissions
construire le meilleur le meilleur pour
l'avenir en tirant justement pour le
futur les leçons du passé précisément en
essayant d'inscrire cette nouvelle
notion dans le droit positif je les dis
à quelques instants pour la première
fois les juges ont reconnu l'existence
du préjudice écologique c'est-à-dire un
préjudice autonome un préjudice
distingue du préjudice moral ou du
préjudice matériel
c'est fabuleux il faut donc que cette
jurisprudence puisse être inscrite dans
la loi
reconnaître et inscrire dans le code
civil justement ce préjudice écologique
c'est fondamental j'ai avec une
cinquantaine de collègues déposé au
printemps dernier une proposition de loi
dans ce sens et c'est je crois la
dernière clé de voûte qu'il faut
apporter à cet édifice sur lequel je
crois on peut tous se retrouver quelles
que soient les bancs il y a
cet édifice juridique il a été construit
bien sûr par la jurisprudence
il était construit
par la loi constitutionnelle avec la
charte de l'environnement avec la
décision du conseil constitutionnel du 8
avril 2011
il était construit aussi par la loi sur
la responsabilité de l'environnement
mais le code civil mes chers collègues à
une fragilité puisque notre code civil
je parle devant la statue de portalis et
bien notre code civil ne reconnaît un
dommage que pour autant qu'il est un
caractère personnel or or
l'environnement n'est pas un bien
personnel c'est un bien collectif c'est
la raison pour laquelle selon la belle
formule de victor hugo il faut madame la
ministre fait rentrer le droit dans la
loi ma question est simple est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à cette petite
révolution juridique
merci madame delphine batho ministre de
l'écologie dû développement durable
jeunes hommes et dames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur sénateur bruno
retailleau l'arrêt rendu par la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation dans
la sphère de l'erika le 25 septembre
dernier à a confirmé la responsabilité
pénale de l'ensemble des acteurs de la
chaîne de transport des hydrocarbures et
au plan civil a reconnu la notion de
préjudice écologique
et je voudrais tout d'abord rendre
hommage au combat qu'ont menée les
régions les départements les communes
des 400 km de côtes françaises qui
avaient été touchées par cette pollution
qui ont tenu bon pendant onze ans pour
mener cette bataille juridique et qui
voient leur combat couronné de succès
cette décision c'est en effet un pas en
avant considérable pour la protection de
l'environnement pour l'application du
principe pollueur payeur avec la
renaissance de la responsabilité pénale
mais aussi de la responsabilité civile
quel que soit le lieu où le sinistre
s'est produit
cette décision fera jurisprudence nous
souhaitons qu'elle fasse son entrée
pleinement dans le droit français comme
vous le savez s'agissant du code civil
c'est la garde des sceaux christiane
taubira qui à t'engager d'ores et déjà
une réforme de grande ampleur de notre
droit de la responsabilité
c'est donc sous sa conduite que ces
réflexions se poursuivront je sais
monsieur le sénateur l'intérêt que vous
portez vous
m à cette inscription nous avons pris
connaissance de votre proposition de loi
mais aussi du colloque que vous
organisez à la fin du mois d'octobre
avec un certain nombre de juristes
spécialistes du droit de l'environnement
je suis certaine que cette initiative
d'ailleurs sera utile pour apporter des
précisions sur un certain nombre de
points qui peut ester en justice au nom
de la nature comment doit se faire la
réparation
vous avez raison de dire que le 25
septembre a été un grand jour il nous
appartient maintenant d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences et je voulais aussi
vous indiqué qu'avec frédéric cuvillier
nous sommes favorables à ce que la
france prenne lors de la prochaine
assemblée générale des nations unies une
initiative afin de proposer un protocole
additionnel à la convention de montego
bay pour construire un outil de
protection juridique international de la
haute mer qui correspondent aussi aux
mêmes exigences
merci mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h15 pour la suite du rapport du projet
de loi par dans autorisant la
ratification du traité sur la stabilité
la coordination et la gouvernance au
sein de l'union économique et monétaire
voilà de retour sur notre plateau ici
salle des conférences les questions
d'actualité viennent de se terminer
dans l'hémicycle les sénateurs les
ministres vont bientôt nous rejoindre
pour on refait la séance